welcome back our next guest believes
that gift wrapping is an art form that
absolutely anyone can learn teach me
please welcome the world's most famous
gift wrap artist alton delaney
i'm glad to see you got the memo on the
holiday garb right i mean we are
twinning this is a great example though
about the importance of presentation and
the same is true with your gift wrap
like if you're going to a party you want
to dress up you want to do your best
it's a celebration you want to look your
best the same thing if you're bringing a
gift to a party dress up that gift so it
looks its best too well how do i do that
because i have to admit i am not a good
rapper so i want to show you a few ways
how you can really elevate even just
your standard box wrap so i've
pre-wrapped these for both of us you see
i've cut my paper so there's not a lot
of bulk i have my flaps on either end
going down so everything looks nice and
uniform there's no visible seams but
when you get to this point there's a
cute little trick you can do and i say
gift wrap is a snap
let's let's all do that together
including the viewers at home gift wrap
is a
snap where's ross when we need someone
to do some sassy snapping right okay but
what you do is you take those snapping
fingers and you run them around the edge
of the gift all the seams and what this
really does it really crisp up your
corner and really makes a tight sharp
gift wrap wow this is really working
super simple and it really takes the
gift a little bit further like my soft
edges became really tight and pointy
sharp and exactly that really helps a
lot now much like getting dressed in the
morning i believe to accessorize
accessorize accessorize and so instead
of just popping on a bow create
something really cool so i've created
these little it's a pine cone it's some
holla you can pick something off the
tree you know you can get some a sprig
of rosemary out of your garden that adds
that smell to the gift as well and then
that just dresses it up and takes it to
the next level it shows that you spend a
little extra time our next wrap is if
you're going to that if you're lucky
enough to go to a holiday party and
you're bringing a bottle of beverage
it's a great
holiday gift for the hostess right yeah
so i'm going to show you how to wrap a
bottle of anything and i know you're
tempted to grab that gift bag at the
supermarket don't do it don't be lazy
here's a quick simple way so what i've
done we've layered a layer of cellophane
and a couple of layers of decorative
tissue paper here and now we're going to
lay down our bottle
and now we're getting a little bit of
the bottom out you're leaving a little
bit of the uh cello at the bottom little
okay and then we're just gonna roll it
up
we're gonna add one piece of tape on the
side
yeah see that's like
mine
like has like 50 pieces of tape well
that's okay too
so tape the bottom so that uh the bottom
is sealed
okay and now we set it up and so now
we're just going to cinch around the
neck of the bottle with a ribbon
we've got our little ribbon on there i
just do a half wait not yet just a
little half knot
because then we're going to add
something to this so
you're going to tie on a corkscrew here
yeah that's that's money
that is money
so smart
so so great holiday gift any host is
gonna love this gift and i want to show
you one last little tip of how to
elevate your bow so you've done a great
job with the bow there is how to cut
that perfect little chevron in the end
oh yes how do i do that here's how you
do you take your ribbon yeah
you fold it in half and then you cut
towards yourself without cutting
yourself
and it creates the perfect little
chevron
and it creates the perfect little
chevron and then i can make a puzzle
piece it goes together
this is so awesome okay i absolutely
love this well nobody likes to get a
paper cut when they're gift wrapping and
believe me i've gotten a bunch so this
show is thankfully teaming up with welly
to protect our little christmas paws
that's right welly has the coolest first
aid kits and handy dandy tins that you
have ever seen so you have the bandage
or the ointment that you need where you
need it and these flex fabric bandages
move with you and stay on just like
these beautiful wrap gifts and guess
what
look at how cool this is
i mean this is something i would truly
put out on my like sorry willie i'm just
going to open these because i want to
show how like awesome these are super
awesome these are like the first aid
kits that you want out
not in
so um i'm really excited to tell you
guys that um everyone in the audience is
going to go home with one
and
i'm really excited
super cute i love the black one
especially
something for everyone
right is so beautiful welly thank you
for making something so beautiful and
compelling a design honestly it boosts
your mood
and guess what
it has inside of it what you need while
the outside looks so absolutely
beautiful so thank you welly for sharing
these with all of us and thank you for
thank you
up my game because design is important
it is presentation is important and
happy holidays and happy holidays thank
you awesome we'll be right back
[Music]